[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 28 avril
c'est ce vendredi qu emmanuel macron
prendra la parole pour détailler sa
stratégie de déconfinement très attendu
où on a appris aujourd'hui lors du point
presse de jean castex
le premier ministre a présenté un projet
de loi sur la sortie de la crise
sanitaire mais aussi un autre sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme de texte
validé par le gouvernement en conseil
des ministres on retiendra notamment la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 2
juin mais avec l'instauration d'un
régime transitoire jusqu'au 31 octobre
débats et décryptage à suivre
il s'agit de la première aide
internationale d'ampleur depuis le début
de la pandémie elle a commencé lundi à
s'organiser pour venir en aide à l'inde
le deuxième pays le plus peuplé de la
planète après la chine a dépassé le
seuil de 200 mille morts un seuil sans
doute sous-estimé la 3000 décès
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures sur
place on manque de tout lits d'hôpitaux
oxygène en cause invariants indien et
vous entendrez le témoignage d'un
médecin à new delhi l'accord commercial
entre le royaume uni l'union européenne
enfin approuvé par bruxelles le bric
site enterré à quoi s'attendre
maintenant le chapitre des tensions est
il enfin terminée pas certain il existe
de nombreux points de friction les
échanges commerciaux dans le rouge
l'accord post break site sur la pêche et
l'approvisionnement du vaccin
astrazeneca
[Musique]
emmanuel macron prendra la parole
vendredi pour détailler son plan de
déconfinement progressif c'est ce qu'a
fait savoir jean castex a aujourd'hui le
premier ministre a présenté le projet de
loi de sortie de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
jean castex qui jugent l'élargissement
de la vaccination à toute la population
prématurée un point de vue qui passe mal
on voit cela avec maxime abers ce vaccin
est à présent périmés
je suis obligé de le jeter en pleine
pandémie je vais donc jeté des vaccins à
la poubelle parce que plus personne n'en
veut dawes jeter à la poubelle créneau
vacants dans les centres de vaccination
une situation impensable en pleine
pandémie est alors que le vaccin demeure
la clé de voûte d'une éventuelle sortie
de crise face à ce constat depuis
plusieurs jours professionnels de santé
et personnalités politiques demande
l'élargissement de la vaccination
je crois qu'il faut débrider la question
de l'âge parce que c'est quand même un
scandale que des doses ne soient pas
utilisés alors qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner
de son côté olivier ferrand nitoo gâchis
pour le ministre de la santé les doses
peuvent trouver preneur
quoi qu'il arrive la règle c'est qu'on
ne jette aucune dose de vaccin personne
ne comprendrait qu'on puisse jeter des
doses de vaccin et donc les centres la
plupart d'entre eux voire la totalité
d'entre eux disposent de fichiers de
rappel des personnes qui ont pris des
rendez-vous qui peuvent être lointain où
des personnes qui sont dites en listes
d'attentes et notamment les personnes
les plus fragiles
donc j'invite les directeurs de centre a
contacté ses fichiers de personnes pour
leur proposer pour l'heure les invités à
venir se faire vacciner
les chiffres sont pourtant sans appel
selon covit tracker près de 270 me
créneau ne trouve toujours pas preneur
et ils sont encore plus de 4 millions de
français éligibles à ne toujours pas
avoir reçu leur première dose chez les
plus de 75 ans quasiment une personne
sur trois n'a pas encore été vaccinés
malgré la défiance des populations à
risques ciblés par la campagne actuelle
alain fischer le monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement écarte l'idée d'un
élargissement anticipées si on l'ouvré
au premier venu une personnes
prioritaires ne sera pas vacciner la
priorité doit aller aux personnes qui en
ont le plus besoin
celles qui ont le plus de risques d'être
malades hospitalisés de mourir sans
attendre certains choisissent pourtant
d'élargir liste c'est notamment le cas
au stade de france où de nombreuses
plages de vaccination étaient encore
disponibles pour les prochains jours en
seine saint denis
45 % de la population a moins de 30 ans
alors ici on commence à proposer le
sérum aux plus de 45 ans et aux
travailleurs à risque dans ce
vaccinodromes géant
on s'assure qu'aucune dose ne soit perdu
mais la stratégie est difficile à
assumer face à la ligne tracée par
l'exécutif
chaque jour ici c'est un peu du
bricolage les équipes sont obligées
d'aller chercher des populations proches
des cibles de vaccination sur des listes
d'attentes plutôt que d'assumer
d'élargir à des actifs et des jeunes
actifs
je crois que la campagne doit être plus
souple réactive et adaptée aux
spécificités des territoires
ici il ya beaucoup de personnels de la
petite enfance de la restauration
scolaire d'entretien qui n'ont pas
forcément l'âge requis mais qu'il
faudrait pouvoir vacciner
faute de voir l'épidémie repartir et les
écoles fermées
pour l'instant le gouvernement ne semble
pas vouloir bousculer son calendrier
vaccinal
il maintient l'élargissement de la
campagne pour les plus de 50 ans au 15
mai et à la mi juin pour les moins de 50
ans objectif annoncé de l'exécutif 30
millions de personnes vaccinées sur le
territoire d'ici l'été
à ce jour plus de 14 millions de doses
ont été injectés en france les annonces
du jour à de jean castex c'est l'objet
de notre décryptage avec nos invités
siens
[Musique]
bonjour alexis poulain bonsoir plutôt à
l'éditorialiste bonsoir bruno mais garda
chef du service de réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière et pierre frey la
libye est maire l air de dreux première
chose alexis poulain voilà emmanuel
macron va donc s'exprimer ce vendredi
soit quelques jours avant le 5 mai
est-ce qu'il a enfin compris l'urgence
de ne pas laisser les français dans
l'angoissé et l'incertitude
alors c'est pas une question d'ailleurs
de tonghua soudain certitude aujourd'hui
on est dans l'improvisation permanente
et donc la communication la sur
communication qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est à peu près toujours la même
séquence de communication qui se répète
chaque semaine un conseil de défense
mercredi avec le conseil des ministres
qui est moins important puis une prise
de parole du premier ministre du
ministre de la santé ou dans l'autre
ministre le jeudi puis alors c'est plus
rare la parole du président même si il
passe son temps à prendre la parole de
manière détournée
lundi il était devant une classe de cm2
il disait que peut-être que 19 heures ce
serait trop tôt pour le couvre-feu puis
parler au maire et on entendait des ddd
à propos de jean louis emmanuel macron a
dit au maire que peut-être il allait se
passer quelque chose
et un petit signe énorme et là jean
castex qui prend la parole pour dire que
le président va parler aux français et
il va nous parler
vendredi donc c'est ultra
présidentialisation de la gestion de
crise fait que et volé le maquereau est
l'alpha et l'oméga de toutes les
annonces décidé en conseil de défense
mais qu'il doit incarner finalement
cette gestion improvisée parce que la
stratégie on ne l'a jamais vu depuis
mars 2020 et donc on attend sa parole
comme si c'était le messie qui allait
nous dire quelque chose d'important mais
chaque semaine finalement chasse l'autre
et on oublie tout ce qui a été dit les
objectifs qui avaient été donnés les
horizons fixer les dates les chiffres
également rappelez-vous en fonction du
type d'expérience on ferme les écoles là
c'est pire
on rouvre les écoles mais c'est pas
grave apparemment la situation est en
train de s'arranger selon jean castex à
6000 patients dans les services de
réanimation
je ne sais pas comment font les
soignants aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils
sont au bord du burn out très fatigués
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
tenir mais les politiques peut continuer
de faire ce qu'ils savent faire de mieux
c'est à dire communiqué
justement on aime un conseil s'est
tourné une nouvelle fois vers les élus
locaux cette semaine pour voir avec eux
ce fameux plan de déconfinement
progressif et aussi territorialisées
est-ce que leur voix elle va vraiment
compter face aux nombreux finalement
conseil de défense sanitaire jugé opaque
par beaucoup on sait qu'il en a fait un
élément clé dans ses prises de décision
si vous voulez nous nous vivons au
quotidien ce que les français vivent son
terrain nous intéresse c'est de faire
remonter le sentiment général auprès du
gouvernement pour que les décisions qui
vont être prises et les annonces qui
vont être réalisés soit cohérente par
rapport à ce qu'attendent les français
savent et l'om est sorti un rapport et
quelques jours qui parle de fatigue
endémique et c'est très intéressant
comme terme qu on revient que les gens
sont usés par une série d'annoncés qui
sont souvent erratique et qui font
perdre la boussole à toulouse l'om s
expliquent bien dans ce rapport que pour
rassurer les français en l'occurrence
ici c'est qu'il faut bien avoir de la
clarté de la transparence des étapes une
durée pour une sortie de tunnel et c'est
ça qu'on dont on a besoin ici vous savez
des commerçants des artisans et chefs
d'entreprise ils sont réellement dans
une détresse économique certes mais dans
une détresse aussi psychologiques et là
vraiment j'invite le gouvernement à
faire très attention à ce qu'ils vont
faire
monsieur poulet 1 raison il ya beaucoup
de communication mais il faut la
transparence et dire les choses une fois
pour toutes clairement oui
est-ce qu'on va ouvrir au mois de mai
les terrasses on pourra reparler
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya plusieurs
choses à dire là dessus ça vient un
restaurateur ou pris à une terrasse il
n'y a pas forcément le faire parce que
est-ce qu'il y en a une déjà on ne sait
pas et est ce que la terrasse va
permettre à son business plan et son
restaurant de tourner si c'est pas sûr
on ne faut pas dire n'importe quoi
mais faut des choses claires précises et
des étapes dans le temps qui nous donne
la sortie du tunnel mais c'est des
consignes mans en fonction du taux
d'incidence
par région c'est du bon sens écoutez
c'est le sens du projet de loi qui est
sorti aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'en
fait on va sortir de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire certes mais le gouvernement va
regarder des prérogatives très important
sur les restrictions de liberté est ce
que je rappelle ce sont des restrictions
de liberté que nous vivons actuellement
c'est pas facile c'est pas la tradition
française et sur le terrain de
l'intervention du président vendredi
écoutez il ya un match de foot il parle
vendredi ils essaient de s'intercaler
avec tous les événements c'est assez
intéressant
enfin bref voilà il faut qu'ils parlent
mais attention parce que sa parole est
en train de fusée comme le disait
monsieur poulin il veut annoncer des
choses à nathan de messi puis des fois
y'a rien donc simplement parler clair
par les transparents synthétique des
sceaux que les français puissent
entendre le message parce que quand vous
êtes dans la situation où on est si on a
une chose les choses claires il ya
l'espoir qui se crée avec des choses
certaines et du coup les gens peuvent se
projeter et ça qui est important
on va regarder avec vous bruno mégarde
année les chiffres de l'épidémie en
france selon le premier ministre la
situation sanitaire
oui les chiffres continuent de
s'améliorer régulièrement pourtant on
voit les indicateurs sont toujours très
haut même si on est passé tout juste
sous la barre des 6000 patients en soins
critiques
est-ce qu'il a raison bruno mais
gardanne d'affirmer que ça va mieux avec
de tels indicateurs
alors effectivement la situation
s'améliore dans le sens où l'épidémie
régresse
le nombre de nouvelles contaminations
quotidienne diminue certes à une vitesse
plus lente que ce que l'on a connu en
mars avril 2020 à la suite du
confinement strict une vitesse deux à
trois fois plus lente alors le problème
c'est que cette fois ci nous avons
atteint une saturation très élevés des
services de réanimation et effectivement
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un plateau
très haut de l'ordre de 6000 admission
en réanimation et il a attendu que ce
nombre décroît extrêmement lentement
donc oui la situation s'améliore mais
nous sommes sur un plateau très élevé et
on espère effectivement que vers la mi
mai avec la réouverture promise
l'épidémie ne repart pas c'est pourquoi
il est très important évidemment de
programmer un déconfinement
territorialisée et très progressif
adapté à la situation épidémiologique
c'est à dire à la fois à l'incidence des
nouvelles de nouvelles contaminations
mais aussi au taux de saturation des
services de réanimation
parce que lors des deux derniers à des
consignes mans les chiffres étaient
beaucoup plus bas oui tout à fait c'est
donc en fait
l'occupation des services de réanimation
par les patients et la comédie 19
étaient plus bas et la vitesse de
régression de l'épidémie un tout un peu
plus rapide donc c'est pourquoi il faut
être un peu plus prudent malgré tout ce
qui change par rapport à la dernière
fois c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
vaccination qui progresse et puis nous
sommes à l'entrée de la saison chaude
donc là aussi le mode de vie va se
modifier c'est à dire on va surtout
vivre à l'extérieur les fenêtres
ouvertes
et donc ces conditions évidemment ne
favorise pas la propagation du virus
mais comme vous le savez évidemment nous
avons cette fois ci des variantes qui
sont à la porte du pays et donc il faut
être de toute façon extrêmement prix
viendrait de régliez l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'est notre annonce de jean
castex prend fin le 2 juin
enfin pas vraiment vous allez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez puisque le
gouvernement annoncer un régime
transitoire jusqu'au 31 octobre
oui c'est une version si vous voulez
allégé qui va permettre de pouvoir
cibler des territoires qui sont plus ou
moins touchés et de faire un peu un
travail en dentelle sur l'idée c'est pas
idiot et on comprend bien c'est l'esprit
de la loi savait que le conseil d'état
est très précis là-dessus c'est à dire
que quand vous êtes hors état d'urgence
sanitaire
il faut une limitation dans l'espace à
dire géographique et une déviation dans
le temps c'est l'esprit de la loi qui va
être déposée
ça répond à vos priorités bon on sort
d'état d'urgence version allégée en
gardant quand même le gouvernement peut
garder quand même des possibilités de
décret et autres pour toujours restreint
les libertés alors on verra on espère
que tout ça va être très pragmatique il
faut que les gens aussi puissent se
projeter au mois de juillet au mois
d'août pour partir en vacances
il faut que le tourisme repartent en
france avec ses des premiers pt au stick
du monde c'est quand même pas rien 90
millions de gens viennent en france
visiter notre pays donc il faut qu'on
accélère sur la vaccination
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu que des
vaccins se perdent et écouter donné
l'idée à dreux on laissera très bien il
ya une chambre de ben y'a pas de soucis
voilà mais en tout cas il faut
absolument que le mois de juin c'est un
mois clé on puisse vraiment monter en
charge en vaccination qui nous permettra
d'avoir des perspectives en juillet en
août
on va parler de la vaccination bien sûr
à l'excès poulain le gouvernement va
pouvoir prendre à des mesures
restrictives tout de même comme la
fermeture des commerces elle limitait
aussi les déplacements finalement ce
régime transitoire
est ce qu'on doit considérer comme une
exception pas c'est tout le problème des
régimes transitoires c'est qu'ils ont
tendance à s'inscrire dans le temps long
et puis finalement à s'inscrire dans la
loi vigipirate
combien d'années maintenant qu'on est
sous sont alors séparés gilles mais
c'est un une veille citoyenne les
régimes d'exception aussi là on voit
bien que l'idée c'est de prolonger de
pouvoir agir vite si on voit des
clusters se former en région pouvoir à
nouveau fermé des commerces pouvoir à
nouveau empêché la circulation des
personnes puisque c'est comme ça que le
virus circule un malheureusement donc on
voit l'idée en parallèle de ça il ya
quand même la volonté d'imposer un pass
sanitaire le pass vert européen
passeport vaccinale si on veut et là les
contours sont très floues c'est à dire
qu'on nous parle d'abord pour voyager ça
on peut le comprendre pour passer d'une
frontière à l'autre même si c'est
difficile à comprendre mais on ne sait
pas s'il va falloir l'avoir avec soi
pour pouvoir aller dans des commerces
c'est le cas en allemagne par exemple où
vous devez faire des tests pour aller
dans certains commerces
est-ce qu'en france il faudra avoir son
qr code sur l'appli stop coville pour
pouvoir aller au restaurant aller au
cinéma et au théâtre
la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot est tout à fait contre mais
elle ne pourra pas l'empêcher si c'est
le cas et on voit bien que jean castex
et gênés 1 il ne disait c'est quelque
chose qui attaquent nos libertés
fondamentales d'une certaine façon donc
c'est un nous
si totalement liberticide assumée comme
telle et peut-être la porte d'entrée de
cette carte de la citoyenneté un convoi
en chine où vous êtes mauvais
concitoyens et ça vous ouvre des droits
ou pas et ce serait la fin de l'égalité
en l'égalité c'est un des trois piliers
de la république liberté égalité
fraternité
si on commence à m ce pass sanitaire en
place quel sera le périmètre est là il
n'y a pas de réponse et c'est ça qui
fait peur dans ce régime transitoire
c'est qu'on voit bien qu'on est en train
de tester
finalement des solutions pour ouvrir ou
fermer la cage des hamsters voir
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller s'ils ont
droit de consommer tel produit essentiel
ou non si la culture est essentielle
ou pas et tout ça alors que les concerts
on l'a vu à nos concerts tests en
espagne a prouvé qu'il n'y avait pas eu
de contamination suite à ce concert avec
des protocoles bien sûr mais donc il y a
des façons de réouvrir autre que celui
du pass sanitaire donc moi ce qui me
fait peur avec ce régime transitoire
c'est simplement la phase test de ce
pass sanitaire qui va devenir l'alpha et
l'oméga de notre vie citoyenne notre vie
de tous les jours
et là on entre dans une autre société
qui est celle de la techno surveillance
du fichage permanent fichage biologique
puisqu'il est question là de votre santé
de votre état de santé
et on ne sait pas jusqu'où ça peut aller
très dangereuse son débat bioéthique
mais sans le plan je veux dire médical
bruno m'égare vanasse que ce pass ali
tar heels essence mince que c'est un
outil nécessaire et utile oui tout à
fait c'est quelque chose d'important
pourquoi parce que tout d'abord vous
allez pouvoir être avertis et alerter si
vous entrez en contact avec une personne
porteuse du virus donc cela va
encourager le dépistage et l'isolément
c'est la fameuse stratégie de dépister
tracé isolé qui certes va devoir être
installé un taux de encore de
circulation de virus est élevé mais
malgré tout il faut l'optimiser
avec ce système effectivement numérique
par ailleurs effectivement le pass and i
ter sera important pour garantir la
réouverture
daigneault sociaux donc il faut pas le
voir comme un va dire limite aux
libertés mais plutôt un moyen pour
permettre justement de retrouver nos
libertés en toute sécurité
enfin bien sûr lorsque l'on va voyager
c'est indispensable
tous les pays vont le mettre en place et
donc quiconque souhaitera partir à
l'étranger devra absolument à voir se
passe sanitaire pour éviter d'être en
quarantaine pendant une quinzaine de
jours
à l'arrivée dans le pays de destination
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
situation de pandémie il y à des risques
vitaux pour chacun d'entre nous si les
contaminés non vaccinés il faut donc
prendre des précautions et c'est ce
moyen qui va nous permettre de freiner
la circulation du virus et on l'espère
évidemment à la rentrée avec une
vaccination plus importante de la
population retrouver une vie quasi
normale en septembre octobre
si malheureusement la vaccination est
trop lente si un certain pourcentage des
personnes à risque n'est pas vacciné il
faut s'attendre en octobre à 1 re
démarrage de l'épidémie comme on l'a
connu en 2020 et donc malheureusement
des mesures de restriction il faut donc
tout faire pour favoriser ce nouveau
mode de vie qui on l'espère ne sera pas
inscrit dans la durée
je tiens à frédéric billets justement
c'est un vous êtes favorable à ce pas ça
n'intéresse que c'est indispensable ou
dit comme alexis poulenc c'est un outil
phare attention c'est un outil qui peut
être liberticide libre il sera quand
même soumis aux parlementaires
oui il y aura un débat parlementaire il
s'est très bien ça peut en ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'il ya des
interactions aussi en europe
un passeport vaccinale si vous voyagez
partir les pays frontaliers et autres
pays demanderont vous soyez vacciner que
vous fassiez la preuve de la première
chose après moi je suis assez
pragmatique c'est à dire que le
passeport vaccinale ça permet de faire
redémarrer l'économie de redémarrer les
commerces qu'on puisse retrouver un
semblant de vie normale
voilà je suis pour mais quelles sont les
conditions qui vont être posées par le
parlement est-ce qu'on va garantir les
libertés individuelles est ce que les
datas les données qui seront collectés
seront parfaitement sécurisé il ya des
questions qui se posent
il faut aussi que l'état soit en mesure
de rassurer les français sur la mise en
place et de service après vente de ce
passeport au maximum sur le plan de la
vaccination en izia alexis poulain il ya
peut-être une incohérence
parce que jean castex a affirmé que
l'élargissement des publics était
prématuré alors qu on s'en souvient le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand a
est affirmé que la population seraient
vaccinés d'ici la fin de l'été les
délais là ça semble quand même compromis
c'est parce que dijon casque avec soi
même dit que les chiffres de 20 millions
à mi mai et 30 millions 1 me joins sont
tout à fait probable sur une première
dose à une vaccination à deux piqûres
la question qui se pose c'est le gâchis
on peut pas continuer comme ça à avoir
des places de vaccination qui sont vides
alors que des personnes qui souhaitent
se faire vacciner ne peuvent pas le
faire par manque alors soit par manque
de logistique d'acheminement des doses
soit par manque de doses mais il faut
dire ce qui est alors il ya le problème
d'astrazeneca et avec une certaine
défiance des populations ou vu les
couacs nombreux qui a pu avoir
on a essayé de rassurer en disant que
vous savez bon alors le bénéfice risque
en fonction de votre âge est quand même
largement du côté du bénéfice mais on
voit que les français rechignent quand
même et préfère certains vaccins à
d'autres mais derrière il ya une logique
de dire si vous souhaitez de lacq ciné
vous devez pouvoir le faire dès
maintenant
le risque c'est effectivement de voir
qu'il n'y ait pas cette douce pour les
populations à risques prioritaires parce
que rétro de demandes de la part de gens
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner qui ne
font pas partie des populations à risque
mais si on voit que ça ne fonctionne pas
dans les métiers prioritaires ou dans
les cases prioritaire il va falloir
trouver une autre une autre un autre
mode de fonctionnement
certains ont essayé du côté du privé
s'est vite ma dose de du commis de
traqueur par exemple qui permet de
trouver un rendez vous rapidement
olivier ferrand qui dit aller vérifier
auprès des centres de vaccination s'il
reste des doses s'il ya une place vous
pouvez à ce moment-là y aller parce
qu'on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
quotidiennement avoir des doses qui ne
trouve pas preneur alors qu'elles sont
programmés dans la campagne de
vaccination bruno mégarde annoncera tout
se vacciner d'ici la fin de l'été
vous pensez à ce rythme on l'espère on
l'espère on voit bien qu'il y à 2
arm est très important le premier c'est
la disponibilité des doses de vaccin je
crois que ce point sera rapidement
résolu et on va dire dans les semaines
qui viennent il y aura suffisamment de
vaccins disponibles pour ceux qui
souhaiteront et vaccinés et puis
évidemment il la volonté de chacun
d'entre nous d'être vaccinés on voit
bien que à un moment malheureusement on
va atteindre les limites des personnes
volontaires il faudra à nouveau acte et
de pédagogie pour convaincre la totalité
des personnes car on sait qu
effectivement s'il restait une
proportion significative de personnes à
risque non vaccinés à la fin de l'été en
septembre octobre
on risque à nouveau d'avoir une nouveau
démarrage de l'épidémie avec à nouveau
un an une saturation des hôpitaux et des
lits de réanimation et donc
malheureusement la mise en place de
fêtes de mesures de restriction et c'est
ce que tout le monde veut éviter
il faut savoir que la vaccination de
c'est d'abord une protection
individuelle mais c'est aussi contribué
pour protéger les autres et bien sûr
permettre un retour rapide à la vie
normale
pour conclure pierre frédéric billet sur
les délais de réouverture des terrasses
que c'est un rendez vous important à
l'animé des commerces non essentielles
aussi il faut rouvrir avant le 13 mai
l'ascension il ya des jours fériés au
mois de mai et c'est vrai que ça peut
être intéressant pour les commerces qui
ont perdu beaucoup de sang froid
d'affaires tout à fait je vais vous
répondre sur des questions et je vais
vous donner en guise de conclusion un
chiffre qui est intéressant alors oui il
faut faire confiance à nos commerçants
parce que ce sont des gens responsables
les consommateurs viennent respecte et
gestes-barrières il n'y a pas trop de
problématiques sur les commerces il faut
leur faire confiance
juste un dernier chiffre en guise de
conclusion à dreux nous avons vacciné à
ce jour en primo vacciner 12 mille cinq
cents personnes
et ceci depuis début janvier
si j'avais les doses nécessaires au
maximum douze mille personnes c'est ce
que je pourrais faire en une semaine sur
une semaine de sept jours
c'est juste pour vous donner l'effort
que nous faisons financièrement nos
collectivités
le nombre de gens vaccinés en plus tôt
moi est à relativiser avec un nombre de
doses maximales qu'on pourrait avoir
qu'on pourrait faire en une semaine
merci beaucoup pierre frédéric billet je
rappelle que cette mère a l'air de dreux
merci à vous également bruno mais
gardanne chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière et alexis poulain
éditorialistes et dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'épidémie de colis de
19 en inde le pays se trouve dans une
situation alarmante avec près de 3000
morts en 24 heures et puis nous
évoquerons le bric site dernier acte ce
matin d'un fonds d'un feuilleton de cinq
années avec l'approbation par l'union
européenne de l'accord commercial avec
le royaume uni a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
la nouvelle menace qui pèse sur
l'industrie une pénurie de matières
premières j'avais un phénomène qui est
le phénomène qui a fait monter tous les
actifs et qui ne sont pas forcément
d'actifs industriels des métaux ou autre
qui est l'inondation par les banques
centrales de monnaie et cette inondation
par les banques centrales de monnaie a
fait tout simplement grimper les prix
vous avez quand même un court terme avec
les livres dynamique entre l'offre et la
demande qui fait qu'avec le kobe 19 mai
les prix des matières premières se sont
d'abord alexandre et c'est le cas sur le
pétrole et que l'on à une lente reprise
notamment parce qu'il ya un pays qui est
moins touchée que les autres elle qui
est le seul pays qui a fait de la
croissance économique
officiellement en 2001 qui est la chine
aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
gesticulations en disant oh là là on va
manquer de telle ou telle matière
première que ça va relancer les choses
et que ça va permettre aux entreprises
de rouvrir
comment vous jugez vous la situation
aujourd'hui après plus d'un an de crise
le tourisme est probablement l'une des
filières qui souffrent le plus de la
crise sanitaire le tourisme et
l'événementiel c'est à dire en fait tout
ce qui crée des flux de population tout
ce qui crée des rassemblements comment
vous voyez là les possibilités de faire
redémarrer tout ça le rôle des élus en
ce moment qu'ils soient nationaux ou
locaux
c'est de trouver le juste équilibre
entre la protection sanitaire et donc la
disparition du virus interne et la vie
économique et la vie sociale
on voit bien que yara clavier économique
qui est touché il ya toute la
psychologie des gens c'est trop long
donc il faut ajuster les protocoles
sanitaires à une vie économique
culturelle sportive événementielle qui
puisse renaître
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on s'en doute est il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens ne s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qui le
droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
on
je
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous appelons des
pratiques professionnelles protectrice
la justice à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez 20h30 heure
française le bilan continue de
s'alourdir en inde le pays connaît une
deuxième vague particulièrement
meurtrière une situation catastrophique
qui préoccupe au delà des frontières du
pays les précisions c'est avec à sirjan
body l'inde
plongée dans l'enfer de la pandémie le
seuil des 200 milles morts a été franchi
ce mardi et plus de 3000 décès ont été
déclarés en 24 heures une première pour
ce pays lourdement touchés par le virus
des chiffres catastrophiques qui
pourrait néanmoins être sous-estimée
selon de nombreux experts le véritable
bilan serait bien plus élevé dans les
villes les crématoriums à ciel ouvert se
multiplient face aux nombreux décès
difficile de s'organiser la tente se
fait longue
nous sommes arrivés ici vers 7 heures du
matin nous attendons toujours
et vous pouvez voir environ 15
ambulances qui attendent chacune d'entre
elles pouvant ou non contenir trois ou
deux cadavres dans chacun des véhicules
c'est comme si vous veniez pour la
crémation vous devez attendre jusqu'à la
fin de la journée pour qu'elle soit
terminée et même là il n'ya pas d'option
j'ai entendu dire que 8 des ambulances
là-bas attendent depuis hier soir
il ne s'agit pas seulement de moi c'est
comme si tout le monde était confronté à
ça comme vous pouvez le voir il y un
certain nombre d'ambulances qui sont là
ça prend plus de 24 heures 48 heures les
gens attendent toujours
j'attends depuis plus de 24 heures
maintenant submergé par les victimes
l'inde tente de sortir la tête de l'eau
des hôpitaux de fortune témoigne de la
détresse ambiante dans le pays
les que pour obtenir de l'oxygène ne
cesse de s'allonger dans certaines
villes la communauté internationale se
mobilise face à cette catastrophe
sanitaire
la france et l'allemagne ont promis des
conteneurs d'oxygène et dead médical qui
devrait arriver les prochains jours les
premières cargaisons de matériel en
provenance du royaume uni ont déjà été
réceptionné par les autorités indiennes
ce mercredi boris johnson et le
secrétaire d'état britannique chargé de
l'asie ont témoigné leur soutien à la
population indienne
je sais que les pensées des députés de
toute la chambre sont avec le peuple
indien
nous soutenons l'inde avec des
équipements médicaux vitaux et nous
continuerons à travailler en étroite
collaboration avec les autorités
indiennes pour leur apporter l'aide
supplémentaire dont elles pourraient
avoir besoin les scènes déchirantes qui
se sont déroulés en inde ces derniers
jours nous ont tous choqués
la pandémie a entraîné d'horribles
souffrances humaines et nous adressons
notre solidarité et nos condoléances au
peuple indien en ces moments difficiles
je suis heureux que d'autres pays
répondent également aux besoins de
l'inde
la pandémie a montré l'importance d'une
action internationale
personne n'est en sécurité tant que tout
le monde ne l'est pas nous continuerons
donc à travailler en étroite
collaboration avec le gouvernement
indien pour l'aider à relever l'énorme
défi auquel il est confronté et nous
continuerons à montrer notre solidarité
avec le peuple indien
outre l'europe la chine et les etats
unis ont également promis de venir en
aide à l'inde
objectif accélérer la campagne de
vaccination afin de ralentir le virus
les autorités américaines devraient
fournir de la matière première pour la
fabrication de vaccins
la russie quant à elle a prévu d'envoyer
une première cargaison de spoutnik vais
d'ici la fin de la semaine
lors d'un entretien téléphonique
vladimir poutine a promis aux premiers
ministres indien à rennes drame audi une
aide humanitaire d'urgence
la russie doit cheminer au total plus de
22 tonnes de matériel et nous avons
recueilli le témoignage d'un médecin
généraliste à new delhi il décrit une
situation catastrophique le résultat
selon lui d'un relâchement de la
population vis-à-vis à des gestes
barrières et de l'organisation aussi de
plusieurs grands rassemblements écouter
le feu pourquoi cette deuxième vague au
début de la pandémie
les gens étaient affolés ils avaient
très peur pénètre leur a donné des
consignes des mesures de précaution
comme le port du masque la distanciation
sociale le lavage de mains et bien
d'autres qu'il respectait attentivement
dans un contexte anxiogène mais un an à
pas
c'est depuis et le gouvernement lui même
a déclaré que la pandémie était sous
contrôle mais les gens sont devenus un
peu laxiste avec la distanciation le
port du masque les rassemblements et
cela pourrait être une des raisons
avec la lassitude
il y a eu un phénomène de relâchement et
le gouvernement a dit très clairement
que les mesures indiennes contre la
pandémie était très efficace que le
monde entier les admirer et je pense que
les gens ont baissé la garde et que cela
pourrait être une des raisons de la
deuxième vague
par ailleurs c'est peut être également
une question de politique
il y a un ou deux mois il y a eu un
grand rassemblement religieux en inde
que l'on appelle kumbh mêla
c'est un festival religieux rassemblant
des millions et des millions de
personnes
un tel rassemblement n'aurait pas dû
être autorisée en période de pandémie
mais le gouvernement a donné son feu
vert et il y a eu jusqu'à 150 mille
participants à une cérémonie dans une
ville ce qui a sans doute renforcé la
transmission de la maladie
je vis à delhi j'travaille adélie j'y
suis médecin généraliste
la situation est grave
à delhi il y à une pénurie d'oxygène
tous les lits sont occupés dans les
hôpitaux on manque souvent de
médicaments ce qui d'ailleurs est très
étrange pour un pays comme l'inde où on
a l'habitude d'avoir un surplus de tous
de médicaments de professionnels de
l'informatique de lits d'hôpitaux mais
aujourd'hui on manque de tout on en
parle avec un pierre tattevin et
l'infectiologue chef du service
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes
un bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur tf1 vous avez entendu ce
témoignage dans un pays de plus d'un
milliard d'habitants
on voit que c'est difficile et c'est
évident de faire respecter les gestes
barrières les restrictions sanitaires
comment là on peut sortir de cette
situation à votre avis ils sont un
niveau de tension des systèmes
hospitaliers qui roulait très difficile
car j'ai été très riche en informations
notamment le fait qu'ils n'ont pas
suffisamment de postes d'oxygène par
exemple pour les gens qui en ont besoin
donc c'est difficile avec autant de
distance de savoir comment ils taureaux
sont sortis risque d'y avoir beaucoup de
dégâts humains
alors justement le pays bénéficie
désormais d'une aide internationale
inédite depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire c'est la première d'une telle
ampleur depuis le début de la pandémie
mais est-ce que ce sera suffisant 6
millions de cas au mois d'avril plus de
200000 morts selon les chiffres
officiels ça serait bien plus on peut
juste espérer que l'aide internationale
et puis la riposte de local parce que le
médecin interviewés disent eh bien quand
même en inde ils ont une grande capacité
de production de médicaments de vaccins
ils ont des médecins qui sont de grande
valeur en général donc tout ça permettra
de limiter un peu la casse mais on sent
bien la tension qui actuellement dans
les grandes villes comme new delhi ou
bombay que ça va sans doute se chiffrer
à beaucoup plus concernant l'aide
internationale l'aide internationale
elle vient des dpi de puissance de
grande puissance qui gère même parfois
difficilement cette crise sanitaire par
exemple en france
la france peut faire parvenir du
matériel de soins alors que les
soignants ici se plaignent du manque de
moyens et de ressources 1 il est
important de toujours essayer de
raisonner avec de la solidarité c'est à
dire c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas tous les
moyens dont on aurait besoin où on est
quand même
actuellement semble difficultés pour ce
qui est des postes d'oxygène par exemple
pour ce qui est du matériel de
protection donc si on peut faire un peu
de solidarité et trans et les choses
dont on a pas besoin immédiatement
maintenant je crois qu'il faut le faire
il faut pas se dire il ya quelques mois
aux moquettes ça donc on va tout faire
des cours ou pour être sûr de ne jamais
avoir de puiser là on se retrouve dans
cette situation il ya ce variant indiens
aussi qui est inquiétant qui inquiète
beaucoup les pays européens
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur ce variant
indien alors on n'en sait pas beaucoup
bah pas grand chose actuellement elle se
mariant indien il est préoccupant parce
qu'il a deux mutations qui sont toutes
les deux associés a probablement une
plus grande de transmission mais par
contre l'exemple de new delhi d'une des
villes souffrent le plus avec l'épidémie
actuellement il est pas du tout dominant
là-bas d'épidémie à new delhi
actuellement surtout liée aux variants
britannique
donc on fait un peu un raccourci on
découvre a varié en inde et puis la
situation en inde est catastrophique
mais on n'est pas sûr que les deux
soient vraiment lié qu'il faut
surveiller il faut mieux étudier de ce
pavillon indien mais pas du tout
dominante de la part de la vaccination
justement 150 millions de personnes ont
été vaccinées
est-ce que l'inde peut aller au bout
justement de cette campagne de
vaccination aujourd'hui il faut défaut
défaut des vaccins ils peuvent aller au
bout et on vaccine toute la population
indienne est vacciné contre diphtérie
tétanos donc c'est quelque chose qu'ils
peuvent faire maintenant c'est une
question de délai et c'est vrai que 150
millions ça fait moins de 10% de la
population donc c'est pas du tout
suffisant pour pouvoir même atténuées et
d'épidémies telles que celles qui vivent
actuellement il faut arriver à 50 %
d'une population vaccinée pour avoir
vraiment il est traitement aussi un
grand nombre d'indiens utilisent leur md
et vire pour se soigner
ça va rien changer probablement parce
que les infos qu'on a sur l'efficacité
du rem désir c'est vraiment limité s'il
y en a vraiment une c pure commandé par
exemple par l'om est ce qu je suis
réveillé je suis pas mal d'études avec
beaucoup de monde donc aux ventes
solides sur le long le moyen terme a vu
là un système de santé très fragile de
ce pays à quoi il faut s'attendre
il faut s'attendre a probablement un
mois de mai là qui va être très
difficile parce que les hôpitaux sont
déjà saturés alors qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de gens qui cherchent à arrivée
à l'hôpital
et puis après il va se passer ce qui
s'est passé dans d'autres pays ce qui
est plein il va finir par diminuer un
peu en partie parce qu'ils auront
vacciner plus de monde en partie parce
qu'il y aura la protection un peu
naturel des gens qui auront récupéré de
leur co vide donc toutes les vagues
jusqu'ici ont fini par descendre
donc ça peut finir par des cendres est
de savoir jusqu'où et va monter combien
de temps elle va durer c'est vraiment
des fichiers à dire merci beaucoup à
vous pierre tattevin infectiologues chef
du service des maladies infectieuses au
chu de rennes
on part à présent aux pays bas après six
mois de fermeture les terrasses les
cafés les restaurants ouverts
aujourd'hui
cet assouplissement des restrictions
partie de la population reste mécontente
des mesures encore en vigueur hier ils
étaient plusieurs centaines de
manifestants à s'être réunis dans les
rues d'athènes pour protester contre le
choix du gouvernement
quant à mme auclair le 27 avril journée
de fête nationale aux pays-bas ce mardi
les néerlandais célébrer le 54ème
anniversaire de leur roi willem
alexander cet événement
traditionnellement placée sous le signe
de la liesse populaire a également été
l'occasion d'une importante
manifestation contre le gouvernement
les restrictions contre le coc vie 19 et
la politique vaccinale les gens se
battent pour la liberté comme nous
faisons tous à travers le monde
[Musique]
il y a un groupe de gens qui sont
censurés par ce qu'ils veulent
s'exprimer pour leur propre libre
arbitre on leur a refusé de dire par
exemple qu'ils veulent prendre leurs
propres décisions sur leur vie sur leur
corps sur la vaccination ou non de leurs
enfants
le gouvernement n'est pas bon hier ils
ont dit que nous allions donner des
millions à l'inde mais nous avons besoin
de cet argent aux pays bas il faut
d'abord commencer par son propre peuple
l'alimentation les banques de nourriture
je ne sais pas comment le dire en
anglais mais nous avons besoin de
maisons
nous avons des gens sans maison ils
dorment sous les ponts il faut d'abord
commencer avec son propre peuple
et si tout va bien alors on peut penser
au reste en janvier dernier une partie
de la population avait déjà exprimé son
mécontentement
de violents affrontements avaient alors
éclaté entre les manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre
le rassemblement de ce mardi intervient
alors que le gouvernement allège les
restrictions en place contre le coc vite
19 ce mercredi depuis 4h30 7 nuits le
couvre feu a été levé dans le pays
les bars et restaurants pourront quant à
eux servir en terrasse entre midi et 18h
près de cinq ans après leur afin d'
homme de juin 2016 la dernière pièce de
l'épée de six breaks site est enfin
rangé le parlement européen a approuvé
ce matin à une écrasante majorité
l'accord commercial post break signé
avec londres le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson a salué la
dernière étape d'un long voyage
le président du conseil européen charles
méchas lui a salué le début d'une
nouvelle ère regarder je salue
chaleureusement les résultats du vote du
parlement européen sur l'accord de
commerce et de coopération
il marque une avancée majeure dans les
relations union européenne royaume uni
et ouvre une nouvelle ère
l'union européenne continuera à
travailler de manière constructive avec
le royaume uni
en tant qu'ami et partenaire important
l'accord de commerce et de coopération
entre londres et bruxelles
et de fait en application depuis le 1er
janvier 2021 à ce texte
il fixe le cadre des relations entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
désormais état tiers de lieux échanges
commerciaux mais aussi coopération
administrative co contient exactement
sept accords post break site voici en
bref et en images les grandes lignes du
traité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on en parle avec guillaume klossa
fondateur du think tank européen
europanova bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
cet accord commercial est ce qui la met
fin aux tensions entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni bonsoir
s'est montré d'abord cet accord
commercial c'est une bonne chose qu'il
soit ratifié dans la pratique en fait il
est opérationnel depuis le 1er janvier
mais ce qu'on a vu c'est que même si il
ya des relations qui existent désormais
de manière organisée entre royaume uni
et l'union européenne
il ya des très fortes tensions qui
existent des deux côtés tension sur les
vaccins les britanniques ont réussi leur
politique de vaccination mais ils n'ont
réussi uniquement parce que la recherche
sur les vaccins by one tech et
astrazeneca avait été financé par
l'union européenne par le conseil
européen de la recherche et que les
européens ont bien voulu leur donner
deux tiers les vaccins qui ont permis de
vacciner elle et les britanniques sans
ça il n'y avait pas de politique
vaccinale possible au royaume uni et
puis et donc les européens l'union
européenne s'est comporté avec le
royaume uni comme si le royaume uni
était dans l'union européenne et a
contrario le royaume uni a fait une
politique de promotion de sa politique
vaccinale sans jamais mentionner le fait
que ces vaccins avaient été payés par
réunion et qu' ils venaient de l'union
européenne donc ça c'est une première
sous le nom selon une deuxième source de
tension qui est l'irlande l'irlande du
nord
c'est que dans la pratique il ya des
contrôles douaniers qui doivent être
faits au royaume uni pour tous les pays
tous les produits qui vont en irlande du
nord
c'est ces contrôles ne sont pas fait et
on voit en irlande une dynamique de
réunion des deux parties de guirlandes
et donc un risque de dissolution du
royaume
donc ça fait 2 tensions très fortes
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni puis la troisième c'est que la force
du royaume uni si sa place financière et
que depuis depuis janvier on voit toute
une série
d'entreprises financières déplacer une
partie de leurs activités alors un peu à
paris mais surtout à amsterdam francfort
et milan
ce qu'il remet en cause le rôle comme
très grande place financière mondiale de
l'eau et sur le plan commercial
on voit que les exportations du
royaume-uni vers l'union européenne son
premier partenaire commercial ont chuté
de 50% des très mauvais présente reculé
alors que les règles les exportations de
l'union européenne vers le royaume uni
ont chuté uniquement de 2 1%
donc au final on voit que le royaume uni
et satellisé par rapport à l'union
européenne puis dernière chose vous
rappeler que boris johnson avait promu
l'idée du bio whole britten ligue
royaume uni qui reprenait une dimension
mondiale qui renforçait ses liens avec
les pays du commonwealth
or les pays du commonwealth n'ont pas
été du tout solidaire au niveau vaccine
and par rapport aux ennemis le royaume
uni allait signer un accord avec l'inde
et finalement le royaume uni n'a pas pu
tenir obtenir deux axes un indien
le même qui n'a pas pu obtenir le vaccin
depuis les etats unis
donc finalement ce qu'on voit c'est que
sur les britanniques qui sont très
dépendants de l'union européenne avec
une politique de communication qui va à
la reverse et qui joue la carte de la
souveraineté engouement en fait toutes
les coopérations et tous les gains qu
apporte l'union au royaume uni et
l'accord de pêche un pasteur excite
l'accord de pêche il va il va rester
temporaire encore encore cinq ans la
difficulté c'est que les producteurs de
poissons britanniques ont comme premier
marché encore une fois l'union
européenne et donc il va sans doute être
négociés chaque année à partir de 2026
mais il faudra trouver un équilibre qui
fasse que les les producteurs
britanniques puissent vendre leurs
poissons puissent vendre dans leur
pression dans l'union européenne
et aujourd'hui on voit que pour certains
produits marins comme les crustacés les
moules les huîtres les exportations ne
se font plus de manière fluide parce que
il faut des contrôles qui n'existait pas
qui n'existait pas avant
et donc il ya toute une partie des
débouchés qui ont été perdus pour pour
les entreprises de pêche de pêche les
britanniques et il ya des tensions très
fortes sociales notamment parce que les
pêcheurs se rendre compte que cette
affaire n'est pas bonne pour eux et vous
pensez que cet accord commercial il va
permettre assez rapidement de
rééquilibrer les échanges commerciaux
c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr parce que
l'accord commercial
on l'a officialisé aujourd'hui mais il
fonctionnait déjà depuis le 1er janvier
est donc alors on a vu en effet que le
problème c'est qu'à plein de contrôle
qui se sont qui se sont rajoutés et
c'est pas parce que il n'y a pas de
droits de douane qui a pas de contrôle
et où on voit vos images
c'est toute une série de petites
complexité qui fait que le commerce est
devenu un peu voire beaucoup plus
difficile selon les les secteurs et donc
je pense qu'on va assister un
réquilibrage mais on ne reviendra pas à
la situation antérieure
donc c'est pas bon pour les mécaniques
ce que les britanniques souhaitent faire
maintenant c'est d'essayer de négocier
un accord trans pacifique donc avec les
pays asiatiques mais les pays asiatiques
sont beaucoup plus compétitifs que le
royaume uni donc c'est pas une bonne
chose non plus
on voit que c'est la stratégie
britannique en matière commerciale n'est
plus du tout unico évidente
le royal et les états à berne et le
royaume uni qui peut se tourner un peu
plus vers les etats unis aussi
oui mais vous voyez que le président
américain ne souhaite pas offrir une
quelconque facilité au premier ministre
boris johnson donc ça sera peut-être
pour son successeur le
le président américain buy den considère
que le départ britannique fragilise une
étude dans l'union européenne et que par
ailleurs le premier relais des états
unis au sein de l'union européenne
donc le royaume uni n'est plus là donc
le rôle stratégique du royaume uni est
bien moindre pour les américains là le
royaume uni a perdu en importance
géopolitique pour les états unis
c'est devenu vraiment à un satellite
soit l'union européenne soit des états
unis c'est le choix qui doit faire être
satellite de qui mais il ya plus
d'indépendance et a priori a plus
vraiment de souveraineté puisque ils
sont obligés comme nouveaux titres ont
rappelé de respecter les règles les
législations européennes s'ils veulent
exporter exporter leurs produits au sein
de l'union européenne ou à celle
entreprise et donc ça veut dire que
alors qu'ils n'ont plus leur mot à dire
sur les régulations européennes
je crois que c'est vraiment une perte de
souveraineté majeur pour le royaume uni
merci beaucoup à vous guillon klossa
fondateur du think tank européen
robin nova est resté avec nous pour la
seconde partie de l'émission
nous parlerons du projet de loi
antiterroriste présenté aujourd'hui en
conseil des ministres un texte qui
permet entre autres de surveiller les
données des internautes alors seront
tous surveillés
ce sera l'objet de notre décryptage
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adepte de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
e
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides
la loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà
interdit de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est
juste que le légat fall ne l'appliquent
pas la justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu les big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont l'un des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes coups
politiques n'a jamais été obligé de dire
la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent à l on soit vient des lignes
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême un
budget annexe de cet été
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
de suite voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 28 avril un futur pas
sanitaires pour l'accès à des événements
sportifs ou culturels une possibilité
pour jean castex
il est déjà expérimenté depuis une
semaine dans les avions en direction de
corse le premier ministre a précisé
qu'il s'inscrit dans une initiative
européenne
de son côté bruxelles envisage un pass
green on le rappelle le chef du
gouvernement a annoncé la fin de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire à partir du 2 juin
suivi d'un régime transitoire jusqu'au
31 octobre
on en saura plus ce vendredi avec la
prise de parole des manuels macro le
gouvernement sur le front sanitaire et
sécuritaire
il a également adopté en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi anti
terroriste il s'agit de s'adapter aux
nouvelles menaces selon les mots de jean
castex le texte prévoit notamment la
surveillance des anciens détenus pour
terrorisme et le contrôle des données de
connexion sur internet des français
alors risquons-nous d'être sous
surveillance numérique au nom de la
sécurité nationale
nous poserons la question à nos invités
[Musique]
100 jours à la maison blanche 100 jours
au pas de charge sur tous les dossiers à
la veille de ce cap symbolique joe biden
prononcera ce soir son premier discours
devant le congrès à l'occasion de faire
un premier bilan sur sa politique
intérieure et extérieure rupture ou non
avec son prédécesseur et quel programme
international à venir nous y répondrons
dans cette émission
[Musique]
un conseil des ministres ce matin au
menu l'adoption du projet de loi de
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
bons d'achat à prévoir sur les
restrictions de circulation soient levés
dès le 3 mai que le couvre feu prenne
fin le 2 juin
jean castex a annoncé qu emmanuel macron
présentera vendredi les perspectives du
déconfinement et le pass sanitaire lui
pourrait être élargie à de grands
événements selon premier ministre se
passe déjà en vigueur en france depuis
la mi-avril pour les avions vers la
corse est également au menu des
discussions européennes l'union
européenne qui espère son entrée en
vigueur au mois de juin un projet
ambitieux qui va tenter d'aligner les
mesures dans toute l'europe midi et ce
qui fit un passeport sanitaires voilà ce
que les pays du vieux continent veulent
mettre en place dès le mois de juin
prochain
ce mercredi le parlement européen a
donné son accord à la généralisation
d'un certificat vert afin de rétablir la
libre circulation dans l'espace schengen
après les couacs en série sur la
vaccination et d'autres restrictions qui
diffèrent d'un pays à l'autre
à l'échelle de lieux bruxelles espère
une forme d'harmonisation pour la saison
touristique et ce week end à liverpool
est écrit d'autres techniques comme
celle ci nous pouvons tenir nos
promesses sur le plan politique et la
solution technique sera prête à temps
si nous ne le faisons pas nous risquons
une fragmentation à travers l'europe
avec lui nul titude de solutions
nationales éventuellement incompatibles
nous risquerions d'avoir différentes
variétés de documents qui ne peuvent
être lus et vérifier dans d'autres états
membres
nous risquerions la propagation de
documents falsifiés et avec elle la
propagation à la fois du virus et de la
méfiance des citoyens d'origine
dans un premier temps réticente à l'idée
d'un tel procédé
la france est depuis le 19 avril le
premier état de lieu à mettre en place
un pass sanitaires le document est pour
le moment expérimentés sur certains vols
à destination de la corse et sera étendu
à l'outre-mer à partir de la semaine
prochaine
plusieurs membres des 27 se montre plus
que réticent à l'égard de ce certificat
vert c'est le cas notamment de la
belgique et de l'allemagne
instaurer un passeport vaccinale à
l'échelle de l'europe avant l'été un
défi qui s'annonce périlleux pour
bruxelles et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean-pierre terne amian président
du rps médecins libéraux auvergne et
rhône alpes 1 bonsoir à vous merci
d'être avec nous ce revers t france en
direct l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne qui doivent être prêts pour
la mise en place donc ne sont pas
salutaire sera le 17 juin prochain c'est
envisageable a selon vous techniquement
je ne sais pas politiquement je suis
tout à fait sceptique
pourquoi et parce que si vous voulez on
a en 2018 je suis allé plaider au
parlement européen de la santé à
bruxelles sur un carnet de vaccination
électronique européens savent et ross
avait recueilli l'assentiment des gens
c'était une expérience qu'on avait lancé
en france et nul n'est prophète dans
notre pays
la cnam trouvé le moyen on va dire de
récuser cet outil est quand même pas mal
si vous voulez qui a été adopté par le
grand duché du luxembourg et je suis
dubitatif si vous voulez sur ses
réalisations dans le délai imparti après
je rappelle quand même que on a 2 pouces
pour ceux qui voyagent beaucoup et en
particulier dans les destinations va
dire lointaine où la fièvre jaune la
fièvre un mari qui a été vrai dire c'est
un virus découvert à dakar par
l'institut pasteur 1928 elle parle à
tous incarnés on va dire de vaccination
jaune et noir a un passeport
ça ne pose aucun problème d'avoir ce
carnet de vaccination et je suis surpris
si vous voulez que l'état français
disent oh là là je vais vite et puis
maintenant je suis comme thézac alors
que lorsque l'on vend en guyane
otez moi d'un doute c'est quand même un
département d'outre-mer la guyane et
bien qu'il faut impérativement avoir ce
passeport
si l'on vous raterez pas et c'est vrai
que lors d'un voyage dans certains pays
on ne peut pas y entrer si on n'a pas
son terme et de vaccins avec la fia
dans beaucoup de pays africains
notamment ce passeport avec ce passeport
vaccinale vous pensez que en france on
en fait trop on débat trop là-dessus
inutilement
oui très clairement si vous voulez on
nous aurait écouté on aurait on va dire
un carnet de vaccination électronique on
aura un registre vaccinale on aurait une
aide à la décision
alors qu'on a un système canard boiteux
jaurès ivac système informatique
vaccination qui comme en panne
régulièrement où il n'y a pas de
collecte
on va dire des données on va dire de
pharmacovigilance et d'effets
secondaires ou c'est indigents comme
système on a complètement raté le coche
en france le luxembourg a été tué dans
la probable demande aux états vont
suivez donc son état de par le monde en
afrique en amérique du sud après la
france est en capacité
mais vous savez ce que c'est le 27
différentes france c'est faux
deux ans et bien au 1er janvier 2022
l'outil qu'on a développés qui est on va
dire un outil public le carnet de
vaccination électronique avec un nico je
peux montrer qui correspond à on va dire
à un carnet de vaccination sera
compatible avec n'importe quelle masse
coronale donc le français qui a sauvé le
tri nations il y en a plus d'un million
sera en capacité
on va dire de montrer sans l'état
vaccinal moi j'ai rentré par exemple que
j'ai eu une double vaccination je suis
âgée j'ai largement plus de 60
donc j'ai été baptisé oprisor dès début
janvier donc fait rentrer les données de
temps je peux montrer le code-barres bon
alors le problème c'est que les
campagnes de vaccination elles sont
inégales au niveau européen au franc ça
avance a aussi un rythme plutôt lent
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire donc
c'est vrai que ça pose quand même la
question des des libertés certains
moments être les et d'autres non je
crois que c'est pas il faut pas
raisonner en termes de liberté ou pas je
reprends l'exemple du passeport papier
noir et jaune
vous ne pouvez pas vous déplacer sur le
territoire français en guyane si vous
n'avez pas ce document vous ne pouvez
pas aller en afrique ce n'est pas ce
document pouvait pas aller dans
certaines parties de l'asie du sud-est
sans se documenter au contraire la
capacité de poule
à se déplacer de nous rendre notre
liberté de voyage qui est importante
je pense que c'est ça si vous voulez
après que l'on ait des sécurité on a
quand même un gpd on a des lois de
sécurité avec la cnil qui sont quand
même trapu en europe et en france
donc ça c'est vraiment pas un souci pour
moi par contre ce que les français
veulent c'est réellement pouvoir voyager
et être protégés et je suis d'accord
avec vous sur la vaccination avec on va
dire le recul que l'on a de
l'acceptation de l'astra zeneca on est
en train de couler on va dire la
campagne vaccinale à terme si on trouve
pas de solutions de remplacement
il y en a pas il n'y a pas de vaccin
disponibles sur ce pass sanitaire
justement jean castex et il a évoqué ce
matin et là il a évoqué son utilisation
pour l'entrée à des concerts ou à des
événements sportifs
bon ce sera soumis de toute façon c'est
une décision qui sera soumise aux
parlementaires mais est ce que la
communication justement gouvernementales
à propos de ce pass sanitaire parce que
cela pose des questions s'il ya beaucoup
d'hésitation on avance on recule
oui mais chercher francion ça vous
surprend
sincèrement vous pouvez pas rentrer dans
une salle de cinéma dans un dindon stade
pour aller voir un match
selon l'équipe l'ol fut lyonnais
groupama stadium si j'ai pas mon billet
avec monk otmar c'est pas choquant si je
dois pouvoir voir mes amis et on va dire
pouvoir voyager c'est pas choquant quand
la barre comment on va perdre
pratiquement une heure pour contrôler
mes bagages mais en plus cela va me
prendre dix secondes de montrer un
code-barres que j'aurais peut-être enfin
sur mon téléphone portable ou ça me
choque pas après midi soit effacée à la
fin du vol je trouve ça normal
c'est vrai qu'il ya des sondages qui
montrent que les français sont pas
forcément favorables à la mise en place
d'un pass annie terme oui mais
rappelez-vous une chose madame c'est que
les français n'étaient pas favorables à
la vaccination
et dieu sait si on a eu un retard à
l'allumage
je vous rappelle quand même que nos
autorités publiques ont quand même
commencé à se préoccuper d'un carnet de
vaccination de la vaccination à
l'automne 2020 or on était en zone 2
covit depuis janvier 2001 ils ont
réellement
préoccupé de ce schéma là en octobre
novembre
on allait d'un qu'on a les documents
comme ça bon si à ce moment là la
population française elle était jusqu'à
l'été dernier contre la vaccination
ils ont basculé pour la vaccination et
maintenant qu'est-ce qui nous disent
mais je veux pas d'astrazeneca moi j'ai
des confrères qu'il n'y j'ai deux
flacons en mars frigo je sais pas quoi
en faire
on n'arrive pas à les vacciner pourquoi
pas parce qu'on a eu une volte face
on va dire volte face on va dire sur le
modèle de l'allemagne
et c'est toujours le même problème en
france c'est à dire l'absence de prise
de responsabilité de risque politique
j'ai peur du procès donc hommage au
suspens pendant trois jours et ça ça tu
es la vaccination
je rappelle qu'astrazeneca ses 25% des
doses en france jusqu'à la fin juillet
donc on est mal merci beaucoup à vous
pierre argentin damian président us
médecins libéraux auvergne rhône-alpes
l'exécutif se défendent une loi de
circonstance une nouvelle loi anti
terroriste présenté ce matin en conseil
des ministres cinq jours après l'attaqué
au commissariat de rambouillet est le
gouvernement assure qu'elle était
préparé depuis de nombreux mois
au menu aussi ce matin le projet de loi
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
deux grandes thématiques ont conduit
jean castex à prendre la parole à les
détails avec notre reporter katia
technique l'exécutif travaillait sur ce
projet de loi depuis des mois ce n'est
pas un texte de circonstance a prévenu
jean castex
il prévoit un renforcement des moyens
humains pour accompagner la surveillance
de potentiel actes terroristes gérald
darmanin a rappelé que 36 attentats
avaient été déjoués depuis 2010 est
alors ce projet de loi vise à s'adapter
aux nouvelles menaces et utiliser les
nouvelles technologies
il comporte 19 articles qui vont
compléter ou pérenniser les dispositions
de deux loi dalo à sylt de 2017 et trans
la loi de renseignement de 2015
par exemple le traitement automatisé des
données téléphoniques de messagerie ou
encore de connexion sur des sites par
des algorithmes
il faut selon gérald darmanin appliquer
les méthodes de surveillance qui
existait jusqu'ici pour la téléphonie à
la surveillance des traces numériques
car la menace en deux
n'est plus difficile à suivre la loi
permettra également de renforcer le
suivi et le contrôle des terroristes qui
sortent de détention après une
condamnation de cinq ans ou trois ans en
cas de récidive
et c'est eric dupond moretti le garde
des sceaux qui a évoqué des mesures de
réinsertion sociale et judiciaire avec
par exemple des interdictions de
déplacement des obligations de
travailler sans quoi l'ancien détenu
devoir retourner en prison
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
conférence de presse à l'issue du
conseil des ministres
la nouvelle loi anti terroriste présenté
ce matin 10 à pérenniser les mesures de
la loi de 2010 est actualisée aussi
l'arsenal des dispositions qui existent
déjà alors que contient ce nouveau texte
la réponse est en images faciliter les
perquisitions administrative
voici la première disposition du projet
de loi soumis au conseil des ministres
cette mesure n'est pas tout neuf la loi
de 2010 est permettait déjà de pénétrer
chez un individu soupçonné de menaces
terroristes
à condition que la menace soit d'une
particulière gravité
le nouveau projet de loi conserve cette
notion le gouvernement souhaitait
pourtant nuancer la formule pour
faciliter le recours à cette mesure
mais l'exécutif a choisi d'y renoncer
après avis du conseil d'état
le nouveau projet de loi propose aussi
de porter de 1 à 2 ans les mesures de
surveillance pour les personnes
condamnées pour terrorisme et libéré
sur les 500 personnes condamnées en
france une centaine a été libéré en 2020
soixante autres en 2021
en août 2001 le conseil constitutionnel
avait censuré une proposition 6000
de la république en marche à la
fermeture des lieux de culte accusée
d'être liée à des faits de nature
terroriste
le projet de loi ajoute la possibilité
de fermer des locaux indépendants géré
par les associations liées à ces lieux
de culte le but éviter que ces
fermetures d'établissements soit
contournée une personne sous
surveillance administrative est tenue de
résider dans un périmètre déterminé aura
interdiction de se rendre dans un lieu
où se tient un événement soumis à un
risque terroriste particulier
le texte propose également de pérenniser
le recours aux algorithmes controversé
cette technique s'appuie sur le
traitement automatisé des données de
connexion sur internet et permettrait la
détection d'individus isolés
enfin le texte élargit la possibilité
d'obtenir le concours des opérateurs de
télécommunications il porte à deux mois
la durée de l'autorisation de recueil
des données informatiques
la conservation des renseignements à des
fins de recherche seraient permises et
l'interception des correspondances
échangées par voie satellitaire facilité
à la risquons-nous d'être tous
surveillés c'est l'objet de notre débat
[Musique]
bonsoir à vous jean pierre colombet ce
porte-parole du syndicat policier unis
et cyril huet lambine délégué national
adjoint du syndicat pénitentiaire
sps alors d'abord on va regarder cette
réaction du président d'honneur de la
ligue des droits de l'homme qui s'est
exprimé hier chez nos confrères à 2 ème
session
ce sont des mesures qui sont extrêmement
restrictives de liberté
nous avions émis les plus grandes
réserves sur les algorithmes
ce n'est pas sûr de l'efficacité il n'y
a pas de rapport nous sommes vraiment
dans une situation dans laquelle nous
sacrifions des libertés sans forcément
nous en rendre compte
est-ce consacre ici nos libertés
individuelles au nom de davantage de
sécurité
jean-pierre colombiès bonsoir
écoutez ce que ce que m'évoque l'annoncé
des nouvelles mesures des nouvelles
propositions du gouvernement c'est très
simple je pense qu'elle sera la fois
parfaitement inutile dangereuse et
révélatrice d'un échec global surtout
sur l'appréhension du phénomène de la
radicalisation dans notre pays inutile
parce que je ne vois pas comment on va
pouvoir contrôler intercepté des
centaines de connexions vers des sites
que l'on qualifie de dangereux on fait
référence en cela des sites qu'on peut
trouver également sur le dark web ou qui
sont diffusées par anciennement des
chouans al qaïda il eût été bien plus
courageux d'aller fouiller dans le dark
wave de neutraliser en amont ce qui est
attractif quand ceux qui veulent se
nourrir de cette culture mais hélas ça
nécessite d'aller plus loin avec les
fournisseurs d'accès et c'est une autre
démarche qui est qui nécessite un peu
plus de courage et je dirais de je
dirais de volonté politique
elle est inutile parce que tout
simplement vous pouvez pas vous ne
pourrez pas surveiller des centaines de
mise en connexion sur tel ou tel site
on n'a pas le même personnel on n'a pas
la ressource pour ça donc on est de mon
point de vue de ce point de vue là tu
t'en dfid annonce que dans une réalité
opérationnelle s'est dit c'est en même
temps dangereux parce que sinon je
dirais on institutionnalise ce mode de
contrôle et de filtres mis dans les
mains d'un gouvernement qui aurait une
certaine tendance à jouer avec les
règles de la démocratie ça pourrait
s'avérer particulièrement périlleux et
c'est en même temps très révélateur d'un
constat d'échec sur le terrain parce que
ce qui fait la force de la détection
d'un individu fragile et susceptible
d'être dangereux quand ton passage à
l'acte c'est tout simplement la présence
sur le terrain or cette présence sur le
terrain nous ne l'avons plus on a
sacrifié le principe de la du lien
social entre la police notamment et la
citoyenneté et ça on le paye cash on
paye très cher donc on veut substituer
cette absence de relations sur le
terrain qui le verrait la véritable
source du renseignement comme ça l'a été
pendant des années on veut y substituer
une sorte de police ou de renseignement
2.0 alors oui cette loi elle comporte
aussi d'autres volets pas seulement les
voiliers de surveillance numérique vous
êtes d'accord
cyril huet alambic sur l'aspect inutile
de la loi alors effectivement je ne vois
pas grand chose à dire mon cher collègue
de la folie oui c'est mon excuse pour y
faire ses devoirs
parfois quand on dit on a l'impression
d'un punch habitudes parce que là encore
un fonctionnaire qui et qui
malheureusement a été tué suite à des
attentats et que jusqu'à présent rien
habité par clément ni a mis en place
donc voila moi je les partage
après je reviendrai pas sur ce que yahoo
confrères effectivement il ya longtemps
et pas avec des algorithmes qu'on va
pouvoir évidemment des surtout avec une
présence humaine et des moyens des
moyens matériels et les matrices mes
moyens là dessus plutôt que des
algorithmes qui vont être de toute
manière détournée par d'autres d'autres
manières à chaque fois informatique se
détournent de toute manière ce projet de
loi pour lutter contre le terrorisme
il intervient après le crime de
rambouillet jean castex affirme que ce
n'est pas un texte de circonstance qu'il
a bien été préparée avant qu'en pensez
vous est-ce que tout de même ce hasard
de calendrier
il est il nous interpelle jean pierre
colombiès très honnêtement je me suis
déjà exprimé à l'issue de ce drame
tout de suite après en disant qu'une
fois de plus ce nouveau systématiquement
dans le piège de la gesticulation du
discours et de la posture et jamais
jamais depuis des années maintenant
jamais on ne prend véritablement le je
dirais le taureau par les cornes si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi
il ya un vrai problème de fond il ya un
problème sur le terrain qui est
parfaitement identifié il n'y a pas de
faux pas une boule de cristal pour
savoir ce qui se passe dans certains
secteurs ce qui se passe dans la tête de
ceux qui passent à l'acte on sait
parfaitement comment ça se produit mais
on ne prend pas les véritables mesures
pour pallier la mesure et je dirais les
décisions qui pourraient neutraliser en
amont ce qui est en train de se passer
et genre et j'en veux pour preuve une
disposition vous avez peut-être évoqué
c'est celle du suivi médico-judiciaire
psycho judiciaire enfin là c'est à
mourir de rire facile si on peut
imaginer qu'on puisse rire dans de
telles circonstances
mais on veut appliquer à des gens qui
sont convaincus d'une fois qu'ils sont
des croyants tout simplement des
croyants exalté mais des croyants quand
même qu'on veut appliquer à ces
personnages des règles du suivi
psychiatrique
car faut qu'on m'explique est ce qu'un
croyant exaltés ou pas est un malade
mental et est ce qu'on peut
résoudre le problème des allées venues
de ce même pseudo djihadistes par des
règles qu'on applique aux pervers sexuel
franchement je sais tu as c'est assez
désespérant de voir que les propositions
du des gouvernements parce que c'est pas
le sol se limite à des mesurettes ou à
des mesures totalement limitée dans le
temps et surtout qu'ils n'ont aucune
efficacité concrètes parce que en fait
on ne contrôle pas vraiment les
personnes dont on sait qu'elles sont
extrêmement dangereuse selon ce texte
cyril huet l'envi il il représente en
fait c'est un texte qui fait suite à des
dispositions qui sont déjà existantes
dans le cadre de la loi
renseignements de juillet 2015 celle sur
la sécurité intérieure et la lutte
contre le terrorisme aussi puisque vous
dites que c'est justement une loi qui
est inutile comment est ce qu'il aurait
fallu s'y prendre pour compléter les
dispositifs qui sont déjà en vigueur
pour compléter la problématique n'est
pas de compliquer qui essaie de mettre
des moyens des ressources de la
formation de la structure qui est voilà
il faut on a des taux bas et qu'on se
servir de notre dame et il faut se
servir des déformations de terrain et
aux cadets et tu vis l'algorithme au
patrimoine et à que j'ai pondu doigts et
tu avais pas forcément te contourner et
pas c'est pas qu'elle touche à le tenir
comment j'en suis très très peur tech
quoi et a aujourd'hui l'impression on
habite tendu quelque chose parce qu'il
fallait le prendre et le père guitare
parce que depuis les derniers attentats
il ya pas grand chose devrait finalement
en termes de sécurité le premier
ministre qui a quand même rappelé que
cette fois elle répondait aussi et le
ministre de l'intérieur aussi gérald
darmanin
elle a précisé que c'est une loi qui
répondaient
à de nouvelles problématiques des
profils particuliers qui sont de plus en
plus jeune des actes isolés
jean-pierre columbia ce nom mais la
foire faut arrêter de se moquer du monde
on découvre pas aujourd'hui qu'on a un
nouveau profil de terroristes on sait
depuis des années
je rappelle que mohamed merah même s'il
a été formé au yémen il est tout seul il
est bas accompagné dans le cas de ces
actes en tout cas il n'est pas
accompagné d'une bande il a pas autour
de lui
je dirais une structure qu'on peut
comparer à celle de qui a précédé les
attentats du bataclan ou d'un an mais et
puis très très sincèrement ça fait des
années qu'on étudie le phénomène du
passage à l'acte on sait qu'il ya un
terrorisme low cost qui s'est développée
en france et ailleurs d'ailleurs on l'a
vu au niveau des attentats commis en
allemagne ou en angleterre
on a affaire à des gens qui se
radicalise effectivement sans avoir
besoin de logistique qui prête qui
prennent des bhutto qui prennent des
voitures conformément je dirais aux
préceptes de développer par dash qui
invite les croyants à rentrer en guerre
contre les mécréants à l'aide de tout ce
qui peut leur tombait sous la main je je
je fais court mais c'est pas nouveau
c'est pas du tout une forme tombé du
placard c'est quelque chose qui dès
qu'ils étaient déjà connus qui est déjà
connu à la fois des services de
renseignements mais tout simplement
connu de ceux qui s'intéressent un tant
soit peu au phénomène de la
radicalisation dans ce pays
découvrir aujourd'hui des gens passent à
l'acte tout seul et se radicalise face à
leur écran d'ordinateur
excusez-moi si si le premier ministre
l'aperçoit qu'en ce moment c'est que
c'est un petit peu
il ya quelque chose qui ne colle pas
trop dans les rouages de transmission de
l'information
cyril va être lambie
le garde des sceaux il a aussi précisé
qu'il s'agissait de renforcer le suivi
des personnes qui sont condamnées pour
des faits de terrorisme
ça concerne un peu moins d'une centaine
de détenus qui ont été condamnés et
qu'ils vont sortir selon lui aurait
effectivement on a on a à peu près on a
une quarantaine de détenus incarcérés un
don il ya dans notre structure
spécifique
il y en a très peu entendu ce qu'on
appelle les quartiers pour radicaliser a
effectivement l attaque et a fait
quelques années plus tôt chez nous donc
m'ont donné on va les relâcher
est ce qu'il faudrait intérêts la vraie
question c'est qui tombait intégrables
c'est encore autre chose à tâter un
sujet sur lequel il faut qu'on arrête de
faire l'autruche qu'on se penche
vraiment dessus parce que on va en faire
quoi maintenant qu'ils sont sortis sans
prolonger il est question de prolonger
les mesures individuelles de contrôle
oui alors il est proche de troyes 2-1
aura dedans jeu est donc une année plus
ça va faire quoi
c'est votre salle à l'abri question
parce que la problématique est le genre
de détenus ne se sont pas des détenus
qui t'ont réinsérables il faut vraiment
qu'on se mettre en tête qu'on a affaire
à des gens qui ne sont pas réalisables
ce n'est pas possible merci merci je
peux me permettre rapidement très
rapidement sur les contrôles sur des
dispositifs de contrôle comme je le
disais tout à l'heure comparé à bauchi
jaillissent des pervers sexuels
ils sont obligés de pointer de déclarer
leur adresse mais ça n'empêche pas
personne ne les contrôle dans leurs
allées et venues au quotidien donc il ya
des points de suspension et des points
d'interrogation complet dans le cadre de
leur vie de leur vie personnelle donc
c'est totalement insuffisant totalement
insuffisant et puis surtout en décalage
complet avec la réalité
merci à vous jean pierre colombien ce
porte-parole du syndicat policier merci
à vous également
s'ils admettent lambine délégué
national adjoint du syndicat
pénitentiaire sps
et dans quelques instants nous parlerons
des 100 jours de joe biden à la
présidence des états unis quel bilan et
notamment sur sa politique extérieure ce
sera l'occasion de faire le point sur la
politique américaine en haïti rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la nouvelle menace qui pèse sur
l'industrie une pénurie de matières
premières j'avais un phénomène qui est
le phénomène qui a fait monter tous les
actifs et qui ne sont pas forcément
d'actifs industriels des métaux ou autre
qui est l'inondation par les banques
centrales de monnaie et cette inondation
par les banques centrales monnaie a fait
simplement grimper les prix vous avez
quand même à court terme avec les livres
namik entre l'offre et la demande qui
fait qu'avec le coït 19 mai les prix des
matières premières se sont d'abord
effondrée c'était le cas sur le pétrole
et que l'on à une entreprise notamment
parce qu'il ya un pays qui est moins
touchée que les autres qui est le seul
pays qui a fait de la croissance
économique
officiellement qu'en 2001 qui est la
chine aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
gesticulations disant oh là là on va
manquer de telle ou telle matière
première le ca va relancer les choses et
que ça va permettre aux entreprises de
rouvrir
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre l'eau politiques et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde il
répond débit c'est vivre
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous un peu long
des pratiques professionnelles
protectrice la justice à sa part dans
cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez 21h30 heure française en
afghanistan washington rappelle son
personnel non essentiel de l'ambassade
de kaboul
une décision qui intervient alors que le
retrait des troupes américaines se
précise joe biden souhaitant un départ
complet d'ici au 11 septembre prochain
soit vingt ans jour pour jour après les
attaques du world trade center un
retrait américain qui selon de nombreux
observateurs pourraient permettre aux
talibans de renverser les autorités
légales et de reprendre le pouvoir le
représentant spécial des etats-unis
s'est voulu rassurant à ce sujet hayden
prochain dribbler personnellement je ne
pense pas qu'il va y avoir un
effondrement rapide
je sais que d'autres sont d'un avis
différent je pense que le choix auquel
des afghans fait face est celui entre un
règlement politique négociée et gauche
et une longue guerre c'est un choix que
les dirigeants afghans doit faire pour
le bien de la génération actuelle
d'afghans et des générations futures
il existe un consensus remarquable au
sein de la région et de la communauté
internationale contre une prise de
pouvoir militaire par l'état libre à
écouter cette réaction à présent de
l'ancien lieutenant colonel de l'armée
de l'air américaine
ce sera très bien pour les talibans et
pour les parties afghans qui souhaite
travailler avec eux ou se soumettra ce
que je veux dire c'est que les talibans
le dessus les etats-unis ont mené une
série de pourparlers à kaboul non pas
avec les groupes afghans alliés des
etats-unis mais avec les talibans c'est
bien connu
et vous l'avez vous même signalé so we
nous avons négocié directement avec la
plus puissante force politique et
militaire dans le pays et maintenant
nous partons et retirons le reste
détruire de l'otan le reste des troupes
américaines et on rappelle également le
personnel de l'ambassade parce que les
talibans prennent le contrôle
et les talibans vont ressentir
immédiatement si ce n'est pas déjà fait
que nous partons ont leur laissant le
pouvoir sur ces territoires
cent jours après son arrivée à la maison
blanche
c'est l'heure du premier bilan pour joe
biden le candidat démocrate avait promis
d'agir dès son accession au pouvoir en
matière d'économie d'environnement et
d'immigration
tour d'horizon en images des promesses
tenues et de ce qu'il reste à faire avec
dimitri si keita cuisse et grégoire dos
et avec un pib en recul de plus de 3
points en 2020 la faute à une économie
percuté par la crise du coc vide
joe biden était très attendu sur le
terrain social par ses électeurs sur ce
plan là l'ancien vice-président de
barack obama a plutôt répondu présent
comme annoncé pendant la campagne
la suspension du remboursement des prêts
étudiants fédéraux et prolonger la
hausse de la taxation des bénéfices des
entreprises de 21 à 28 % et l'annulation
des réductions d'impôts décidées par
trump sont mises sur les rails mais les
mesures doivent être validées par le
congrès
l'engagement de vacciner 100 millions de
personnes dans les 100 premiers jours a
été tenue très en avance
l'objectif a été atteint le mois dernier
au 58e jour du mandat de joe biden
comme prévu les etats-unis ont fait leur
retour dans l' oms et se sont engagés à
participer à son financement
les américains qui reviennent également
dans l'accord de paris sur le climat et
joe biden a dès son arrivée au pouvoir
signer un décret pour bloquer le projet
kiston xl 'pipeline' de près de 2000 km
de long qui compte des forêts pour
rallier le canada il a aussi abandonné
le projet de forage dans la réserve
naturelle nationale d'alaska
c'est peut-être en matière d'immigration
que joe biden s'est montré le plus
timide la création d'un groupe de
travail pour réunir les familles
séparées par le mur à la frontière
mexicaine a bien été mise en oeuvre
mais le moratoire de 100 jours sur les
expulsions que ce que telle
administration maiden a été bloqué par
un juge fédéral au texas et surtout le
nombre de réfugiés accepter cette année
se rapproche de 15000 quotas fixés par
donald trump
bien loin des 125 mille personnes que
joe biden s'était engagé à accueillir
pendant sa campagne
la question du port d'armes reste
également encore à traiter
joe biden s'est pour l'instant contenté
d'annoncer deux timides mesures telles
que la lutte contre les armes fantôme
mise au point de façon artisanale
il a également commandé un premier
rapport qui portera sur le trafic
d'armes à feu sur le territoire
américain
et concernant le bilan de la politique
extérieure de joe biden à nous
retrouvons claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales
bonsoir à vous que de blanchemaison
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors bonsoir
quels sont les éléments de rupture entre
la politique internationale de donald
trump et celle de joe biden qu'on a pu
constater durant ses 100 premiers jours
le premier élément de rupture c'est
d'abord le retour de la des diplomates
et de la diplomatie
joe biden lui-même à une expérience
diplomatique puisque au congrès il a
présidé à deux reprises je crois le
comité des relations extérieures et puis
naturellement lorsqu'il était le
vice-président de barack obama
il a exigé qu'il a fait plusieurs
missions diplomatiques les diplomates
qu'il a choisie notamment le secrétaire
d'état blinken
et évidemment un diplomate très
expérimenté de même le secrétaire à la
sécurité monsieur sullivan est également
un diplomate très expérimenté en
deuxième lieu c'est le retour vers les
alliés c'est à dire que bayonne a
cherché à redonner confiance à ses
alliés il a reçu le premier ministre
japonais le premier ministre de corée du
sud et il sait tourner aussi vers ses
alliés européens
pour marquer sa solidarité et le
maintien des alliances et puis pour les
autres pour ceux qui ne sont pas les
alliés eh bien il a rouvert les voies de
la diplomatie c'est à dire que y'a les
sujets qui fâchent sur lesquels on est
en opposition mais aussi toujours des
sujets sur lesquels on peut coopérer et
il faut le faire et puis entre les deux
il rit sujets sur lesquels il faut
maintenir le dialogue et c'est ce qu'il
a essayé de faire et c'est ce qu'il
explique qu'il veut faire
en troisième lieu il a réintégré les
anisation internationale les
organisations multilatérales que
monsieur trump avait quitté l'om s
notamment l'organisation mondiale de la
santé dont on a bien besoin dans cette
période de pandémie puisqu'on s'aperçoit
que les situations nationales sont
toutes reliées les unes aux autres et
puis l'organisation mondiale du commerce
qui était boycotté plus ou moins par
donald trump donc restauration du
multilatéralisme et ce qui est
évidemment très important
et puis quatrième élément les droits de
l'homme que les démocrates ont toujours
voulu utiliser comme à la fois les
mettre en avant comme valeur et plus les
utiliser comme moyen de politique
étrangère alors tout ça pour faire une
politique étrangère qui se veut efficace
s'orienter vers les résultats américains
s bac puisque c'est bien ce que dit
monsieur bayh dole et pour le démontrer
comme vous l'avez dit il a pris trois
décisions dès sa prise de fonction
premièrement il a prolongé de cinq ans
le traité new star est un traité de
limitation des armes nucléaires et des
missiles conclu avec la russie
il a réintégré la corde paris sur le
climat et puis il a décidé aussi de
ramener des états unis dans le traité
nucléaire avec l'iran alors c'est en
train de se faire c'est très compliqué
c'est une négociation qui se déroule
actuellement à vienne
et puis pour le reste eh bien il a
également renouvelé l'aide aux réfugiés
palestiniens par le biais de l'inra
organisation des nations unies vis-à-vis
de la russie
il a pris une attitude assez dur mais en
même temps il a tendu la main à un
dialogue il a ouvert une possibilité de
dialogue
et puis en ce qui concerne l'asie il a
pris l'initiative d'un sommet en
visioconférence avec le japon avec
l'australie et avec le premier ministre
indien
c'est ce qui s'appelle le quad et qui
est l'embryon en fait d'une stratégie
radio pacifique
il pourrait s'étendre comme une ceinture
indo pacifique d'états démocratiques
pour contenir la chine alors des
éléments
rupture mais peut-être aussi des
éléments de continuité avec son
prédécesseur
oui alors précisément le principal
c'était évidemment la chine la chine qui
est identifiée comme le principal rival
systémique et l'ennemi potentiel est là
dessus il ya au congrès des états unis
un consensus interparti et c'est un
point très important pour monsieur
buydens spécialiste des consensus au
congrès parce qu'il va s'appuyer là
dessus pour obtenir des accords sur
d'autres sujets et sur d'autres points
de sa politique étrangère
il utilise peut-être d'autres méthodes
que monsieur treuil mais le diagnostic
est le même
la chine est une menace par parce par
son comportement par sa montée en
puissance et par la façon dont elles
plient également
les pays occidentaux notamment les
etats-unis en matière technologique
le deuxième point c'est que weiden veut
une politique étrangère qui répondent
aux besoins de la classe moyenne
américaine et ça c'est un peu nouveau
dans le fond il a fait l'analyse de ce
qui s'était passé à l'époque de
l'élection de donald trump et ge est
aperçu qu en effet la classe moyenne
elle est notamment la loi middle class
était dans le fond tout à fait irrité
excédé par l'accent mis sur les accords
de libre échange et que peut-être il
fallait regarder à deux fois maintenant
avant de conclure de nouveaux accords de
libre-échange donc les états unis ne
réintégreront pas le pacific partnership
qu'obama avait conclu et dont monsieur
trump est sorti ensuite il ya d'autres
éléments également de continuité bien
sûr l'ambassade des états unis en israël
qui restera à jérusalem est qui ne
reviendra pas à tel aviv
et puis aussi d'autres éléments que l'on
pourrait que l'on pourrait énumérer et
la suite la suite pour les prochains le
volet la suite du retour va la voir au
mois de juin puisque entre le
le 10 et le 15 juin le président joe
biden va va passer presque une semaine
en europe
ce sera son premier voyage à l'étranger
et ce voyage a déjà un programme
extrêmement dense qui pourra encore se
densifier d'ailleurs dans les prochains
jours alors d'abord il va assister au g7
actuellement c'est le royaume uni qui
préside le g7 et qui a décidé que ce
sommet se tiendrait en cornouailles
donc il va passer deux jours en
cornouailles avec les autres chefs
d'état de gouvernement du g 7 avec
lesquels il aura bien entendu des
entretiens bilatéraux avec chacun
d'entre eux pendant cette période il
s'arrêtera sans doute à londres parce
que c'est un homme courtois il ira sans
doute s'est levée
la reine d'angleterre et puis ensuite il
ira à bruxelles où il ya un sommet de
l'otan qui est prévu et participera à un
sommet de l'otan
il devra donc rassuré les les autres
membres de l'otan sur la validité de
l'article 5 de la charte de l'atlantique
qui établit que si l'un des membres est
attaqué eh bien ce sont tous les membres
qui sont attaqués il sera aussi sans
doute interrogé bien sûr sur la
situation en ukraine et on verra bien à
quelle sera l'évolution
ensuite après ce sommet de l'otan ici là
il il aura à tenir à une rencontre
bilatérale avec l'union européenne
traditionnellement il y à chaque année
il y en a pas eu depuis un certain temps
desmet union européenne états unis et
bien il y en aura le 15 juin et donc en
belgique dont toujours à bruxelles
et puis par ailleurs on apprend que par
monsieur ouchakov qui est le conseiller
diplomatique du président vladimir
poutine que vladimir poutine serait
disposée à rencontrer le président biden
qui il a tendu la main en disant qu'ils
étaient prêts à dialoguer avec lui à une
date à déterminer
au moins de juin au mois de juin en
europe et donc comme il est probable que
le président biden ne va pas refaire
beaucoup d'allers retours au dessus de
l'atlantique au mois de juin
un élève est très probable que cette
rencontre aura lieu au le 15 ou le 16
juin
mais pour le moment il n'ya pas te fies
ciel à suivre donc merci beaucoup claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
la crise politique elle se poursuit en
haïti le pays s'enfonce depuis plusieurs
mois dans une situation de forte tension
une partie de la population conteste la
présidence de joël moïse et on assiste à
des scènes de chaos en marge des
manifestations une situation sur
laquelle a l'air qu'une soixantaine de
membres du congrès américain dans une
lettre adressée au secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken
ils appellent notamment à ne pas
s'ingérer dans les affaires haïtiennes
thomas boni certains diront que
l'instabilité dure depuis sa naissance
mais force est de constater qu haïti
connaît une période particulièrement
tendue ces derniers mois enlèvement
assassinat et affrontements les images
qui nous parviennent du pays sont
violentes
face à cette situation et comme on en a
maintenant l'habitude le gendarme du
monde a son mot à dire
mais sur ce dossier contrairement au
venezuela par exemple washington ne
soutient étrangement pas les
manifestants et préfère s'appuyer sur le
président en place je venais le moïse un
président pourtant très contestée car
l'autorité judiciaire haïtienne estime
que son mandat a pris fin en février
dernier un dirigeant qui glisse vers
l'autocratie gouvernants sans parlement
depuis maintenant plus d'un an
c'est pourtant lui qui a décidé de se
charger de l'organisation d'élections
cette année des scrutins qui pourrait
jeter de l'huile sur le feu tant la
suspicion de fraude est importante
alors c'est en s'appuyant sur cette
situation explosive que 68 membres du
congrès américain ont adressé un
courrier au secrétaire d'état anthony
blinken
malgré cette situation alarmante le
département d'état a insisté sur le fait
que les élections sont la seule voie à
suivre
alors que des élections seront
clairement nécessaire dans un proche
avenir pour rétablir l'ordre
démocratique
nous restons profondément préoccupés par
le fait que tout processus électoral
organisé sous l'administration actuelle
ne sera pas libre équitable crédible et
que l'insistance continu des états unis
sur des élections à tout prix ne fera
que rendre ce résultat plus probable en
clair le soutien indéfectible des
américains au pouvoir en place risque de
favoriser l'instabilité politique
et de fait les violences pour le moment
la diplomatie américaine a seulement
exprimé quelques réserves sur le
processus électoral en haïti mais
continue de le soutenir financièrement
au travers d'organisations
internationales les membres du congrès
signataires de la lettre
en plus de vouloir changer le braque
américains dans le pays souhaite aussi
revoir la méthode
parmi les pistes qu'ils exposent la
nomination d'un représentant spécial
pour haïti qui aurait pour mission de
rassembler les acteurs du pays pour
soutenir un développement démocratique
menée par les haïtiens eux mêmes
une initiative qui part sûrement d'une
bonne intention mais qui pourrait se
heurter au rejet de toute forme
d'ingérence par le peuple haïtien c'est
un slogan récurrent dans les
manifestations ou des drapeaux
américains sont même parfois brûlés les
opposants qui sont également mobilisés
au sein de la diaspora haïtienne commis
y à washington en mars de cette année
c'est donc une grande source
d'inspiration pour moi de voir que des
organisations et des individus manifeste
pour s'opposer à l'impérialisme
américain en haïti et soutenir le
mouvement en faveur de la démocratie
mais pour le moment la diplomatie
américaine semble inflexible et rien
n'indique que l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche
amorce un quelconque changement sur le
dossier il faut dire que si on parle
parfois de malédiction concernant haïti
frappée par de terribles épreuves depuis
la création de l'état il faut surtout
analyser l'attitude de l'un de ses plus
proches voisins
le pays de l'oncle sam a participé
depuis des années à l'instabilité du
pays notamment par le biais de décisions
d'ordre économique
en 2021 le vent du changement vanté par
joe biden n'a visiblement pas atteint
l'écho des caraïbes on en parle avec
jacques léon emile les présidents de
l'association haïti mémoires et cultures
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt francs 68 membres du
congrès américain demande donc à
l'administration bailon de se tenir à
l'écart de l'organisation du référendum
constitutionnel prévu le 27 juin
prochain c'est un référendum contesté
dans la rue
de quelle manière les états unis sont
ils impliqués dans les intérêts haïtiens
avant avant de répondre à votre question
j'aimerais j'aimerais quand même
apporter quelques précisions
d'abord quand on parle d'haïti
le temps est toujours très pessimistes
il faut bien comprendre qu'il n'ya pas
de souci de polémique pour autant c'est
pas dans un souci polémique ni le
victimisation systématique d'haïti en
tout cas ma préoccupation à moi c'est
d'éclairer les événements vaut mieux
faire comprendre
haïti est aujourd'hui montré que dans le
cas d'haïti il n'y a ni fatalité ni
malédiction il ya des explications au
sujet des événements il ne survienne pas
par hasard
tout ce que vit haïti aujourd'hui vient
que depuis des décennies il n'y a pas
d'état en haïti les élites les
dirigeants politiques n'ont rien faire
ce sens pour construire un état
rien et les états unis comme vous disiez
la super puissance voisine
tout comme la france ancienne anciens
pays colonisateurs d'haïti n'ont pas
aidé en ce sens
ce pays a des ressources culturelles des
ressources humaines et n'en finit pas de
sombrer dans le chaos
il est temps vraiment que les hommes les
femmes les enfants d'haïti et accès à
une vie décente
c'est important de le préciser parce que
quand on parle d'haïti on est toujours
dans des termes durs dans des termes
négatifs
alors aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à
une contradiction ou effectivement il ya
un gouvernement il ya un président qui
est du pays qui est président du pays
donc qui a un caractère national
c'est ici à haïtiano haïtien en même
temps le problème haïtiano haïtiens ne
se règle pas il ne se règle pas de façon
haïtiano haïtienne alors on dit vous
savez dans les manifestations fait dire
aux gens des choses à haïti on leur fait
dire oui pas de
pas de pas d'ingérence étrangère pas
d'ingérence étrangère mais comment
va-t-on résoudre le problème pas avec
les gens en place
en tout cas alors justement suis a même
saisi melanie crédibilité ni légitimité
jacques les hollies et 1000 ça nous
amène à la question que je vous pose est
est-ce que concernant précisément les
états unis vous pensez qu'ils sont
impliqués dans les dents des intérêts
haïtiens les états unis depuis 1915 les
états unis auraient occupé haïti de 1915
à 1934
depuis 1915 tout ce qui se passe en
haïti de politique est piloté par les
états unis tout au moins cautionné par
les états unis où les états unis ferment
les yeux il n'y a aucun doute là dessus
donc la question la réponse est dans la
question
les états unis veille au grain très fort
sur haïti pour des raisons historiques
ce ne sont pas mes propos à moi c'est
l'histoire il le montre voilà donc bien
sûr qui sont impliqués dans ce qui se
passe mais les états unis n'ont pas
voulu s'en occuper le groupe précise que
le précédent président est ce qu'il ya
un sentiment aggraver les choses
personnalité ce qui vient à re sentiment
très fort envers les états unis de la
part d un score que leurs sentiments ils
elles dans le fait d'ailleurs part des
haïtiens du fait que les états unis
n'agissent pas tout au moins tolère
jusqu'ici ce qui se passe maintenant l'a
été c'est ça la source du ressentiment
il faut passer mes profs le président
actuel ces jeunes et leurs gouvernements
légitimes et illégitimes beaucoup bien
comprendre la situation en haïti le
président actuel c'est jovial moïse
que se passe-t-il actuellement dans
votre pays pourquoi votre pays
aujourd'hui et plongée dans le chaos si
on peut dire les choses ainsi puisqu'il
ya une forte contestation
concernant le projet de réforme
constitutionnelle pour reprendre la
chose dès le début le président joël
moïse a été élu en 2016 et lila pas il
est apparu que son élection était
entaché d'irrégularités
donc les élections ont été annulées il a
été réélu si j'ose dire les riches de
nouvelles élections ont eu lieu
il a été réélu en 2017 or il est élu
pour cinq ans la question est les
haïtiens andy et compte tenu de la
situation
comme vous voyez les images que vous
voyez à côté de moi et que les choses
devaient changer c'est à dire que josé
ruiz élus en 2016 devaient partir en
sa réponse a été non qu'il était lui en
fait en 2017
il doit partir en 2022 et les américains
disent oui il doit partir en 2022
tout au moins se taisent en tout cas
disent que les élections ne peuvent
avoir lieu que fin 2021 voilà voilà d'où
vient tout ça et sans compter qu'ils
avec la corruption qui à l'insécurité
qui règne vous avez compris les clients
d'aujourd'hui même des français qui sont
enlevés
donc les états unis veulent le départ de
joe venelles moïse il ne ils le veulent
ils ne veulent pas qu'il parte avant la
fin de son mandat qu'il considère être
voila voila tout tout problème tout
litige viennent de là et donc on est
dans une cité dans une situation
totalement contradictoire in explique
inextricable même si les juristes
haïtiens comme le dit dans le courrier
de votre les court-courriers des 68 élus
et parlementaires américains ont adressé
au département d'état il est très clair
qu'il n'y a plus de légitimité plus de
crédibilité pour ce gouvernement est que
ma foi les états unis persistent à jouer
l'indifférence bien sûr ils estiment
qu'ils ont d'autres problèmes à régler
ça j'ai envie de dire ça se comprend
mais je ne l'accepté ou pas selon vous
les la demande des 68 membres du congrès
américain à l'administration maiden de
se tenir à l'écart de 2
de ce qui se passe actuellement dans
votre pays elle est légitime
je pense et je peux vous donner une
précision
les etats unis sont intervenus pour
déloger des dictatures en 1994 par dont
88 94
pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
des boat people haïtiens c'est à dire
des gens qui montaient sur les bateaux
de fortune qui prenaient le large et qui
arrivait sur les côtes américaines
hélas les amériques ont compris qu'ils
devaient s'impliquer
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas souhaité
qu'il se refasse une chose pareille mais
c'est une situation où les américains se
sentent menacés c'est ce qui manque pour
qu'ils arrivent après l'une des plus que
je décide aujourd'hui à intervenir à
faire quelque chose ils ne se sentent
pas concernés par le problème est dans
le même temps votre pays a besoin de
l'aide internationale
si haïti ne vit que de l'aide
internationale depuis 2010 qui a eu ce
fameux tremblement de terre le pays est
encore en reconstruction
oui la reconstruction on est à 10 % de
reconstruction de ce qui aurait dû être
fait jusqu'à présent le pays a vite vie
et puis comme on dit pendant longtemps
ce sont des ong puis jusqu'à aujourd'hui
même ce sont des ong qui étaient les
institutions sérieuses du pays
quel pays peut fonctionner de cette
manière mais encore une fois je refuse
que l'on rejette la pierre
systématiquement sur le peuple haïtien
c'est trop facile l'élite haïtienne à sa
culpabilité
les la communauté internationale à ses
responsabilités dans la sphère ça c'est
clair
et elle parce que quand on entre temps
qu'on entretiendra la corruption
tant que la communauté internationale
fermera les yeux et toléra ce qui ce
passe en haïti est bon on pourra
toujours dire on fera vingt émissions
pour dire la même chose que le peuple
haïtien croupit dans la misère que la
situation est inextricable
comment voulez vous que des gangs de rue
reejer un pays aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible il ya des idées des galets
c'est le l'enlèvement le kidnapping est
devenu une activité industrielle
commerciale qui n'attend lève des gens
pour des petites sommes notamment
et maintenant il y avait religieux peu
alors ça c'est ce que je me suis dit
peut-être que ces religieux qu'ils sont
français enlevés qui de la perle a été
peut-être que ça fera réagir
l'international la commune merci ça fait
deux semaines yahia
merci beaucoup à vous jacques leo amy
lachapelle dans l'association haïti
mémoires et cultures et c'est la fin de
cette émission prochain point complet
sur l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes rester avec nous sur rt france
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire qu'un autre le
peuple c'était une volonté collectés
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
soul unis vers une forme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]